no i can't think of anything
hiding in this basement
accomplishing
the pandemic
surge the infrastructure bill i think
that was huge and i can see it
everywhere
[Music]
[Music]
helping us out one with the uh and he
hasn't completed it yet with this uh
student loan
we really need that uh we need that that
forgiveness you know he's handling the
border situation
to the best of his ability
with what the cause he's been dealt
and the pandemic i think he's done a
hell of a job with it i don't think he
has one big accomplishment if you look
at what our gas prices are now what they
were two years ago if you look at what
um
all right
yes i
our whole economy's taking a nosedive
everything that the former president
uh did he undid well i think he'd really
doing a very good job
for what he encouraged i think he did
really really good fighting the pandemic
with the
with the availability of vaccines and
and not just us giving out millions of
vaccines to all the other countries so
no i think he was a great president for
the four years that he'll be here for i
think he brought some sensibility to the
whole covid fear
i'm a big believer in science as far as
children i was glad that most the
schools had a mass mandate because for
me
we should err on the side of caution
when it comes to children
at this point i think his greatest
achievement is keeping us out of world
war iii
um
he's doing everything he can
to help where help is needed
over in europe
um
but he's also smart enough to keep us
out of it at this point
plus i do think he's handled
the last bits of the pandemic fairly
well
i'll bring his sobriety to the
presidency bring a sense of
decency back uh
uh bringing uh stability back bring the
thought process back
he's not perfect but
none of us are are we